as we have been focused on the trials
and tribulations of afghans over the
past uh several weeks not to mention the
past several decades past couple decades
at least it might be easy to lose track
of the fact that our own civilization is
falling apart at the seams there's a
viral video which uh picked up steam
after it was reposted by jack bosobiac
which gives us a startling glimpse into
what our cultural collapse actually
looks like
in fact if you didn't know any better
and you look at this video
you would think that it's from not from
america at all but from some kind of
third world hellhole
or else maybe from a hollywood sound
stage where they're filming another
zombie apocalypse movie but tragically
the zombie infested third world
wasteland you can see in the video is
called philadelphia trash and debris
littering the streets homeless laying
all over the sidewalk people wandering
around hunched over
in drugged out stupors
it's a vision of horror and desperation
and gloom
now this i believe is kensington avenue
in philadelphia it's the poorest most
violent part of one of the poorest and
most violent cities in america the
violent crime rate around kensington is
328 violent crimes per 10 000 residents
now for comparison's sake the violent
crime rate for the whole nation
is 366 per 100 thousand
and people who live in philadelphia and
are familiar with this area they'll tell
you that
what you can see in the video is uh is
what that area and much of the rest of
the city
looks like all the time
every day 24 7.
this is it
this is an american city
philadelphia
again a one a once a great city
one of our greatest
historically speaking
now philadelphia may be especially bad
but it's not even the worst and even the
cities that are a little better are yet
still horror shows in their own right
well what you see on kensington can be
seen to a degree slightly better or
worse
in every major u.s city
in fact in our travels last week we
visited we visited several major cities
that looked something like this
we're told that our cities have turned
into these dirty horrifying
crime-ridden cesspools because of drugs
and certainly the drug epidemic is one
of the most prominent most immediate
causes just to give you an idea of the
scope and severity of drug problem i can
tell you that drug overdose deaths have
quadrupled since 1999
and it's not like the rate was
especially low in 1999 to begin with
over the course of those two decades
nearly 1 million people
1 million have died from overdoses
sadly one of the most recent in that
line is the brilliant actor michael k
williams who portrayed omar on the wire
um about another decaying city baltimore
he was found dead of an apparent heroin
overdose this weekend
and these are just overdose deaths we're
talking about this doesn't this doesn't
account for all the many millions of
lives that have been if not technically
ended by drugs still completely
destroyed by them
and families as well
so why is this happening
i think many answers might be given
some of them political all of these
drugged out slums are run by democrats
that's not a coincidence
but then how did democrats manage to
seize control in the first place
and why do people keep voting for them
in these cities
i mean you could if you're in kensington
you could look around and say it
literally can't be worse i mean this is
as bad as a city can get
would i keep voting for the people who
made it this way
or at the very least were in charge
while it became this way
now you might also point to the collapse
of the family
which is which is a factor yeah but why
did the family collapse
you might approach this from the
economic angle and connect it to
poverty and unemployment yeah but why
are so many people in these cities
unemployed especially when there are at
present there are 10 million jobs
available so i think all of these
are pieces of the puzzles symptoms of
the underlying disease but they are not
themselves the underlying disease
and then what happens when we use a
wider lens and we consider our decaying
cities within a broader cultural context
how does everything else fit into this
picture what about the
skyrocketing numbers of people who've
grown dependent on legal drugs
prescribed to them by doctors especially
psychiatric drugs what about the
enormously high rates of depression
anxiety what about our experiences with
covet all of these millions of people in
america and across western civilization
who have been eager to give up their
liberty for the tenuous promise of
safety
people who even after being vaccinated
still won't leave the house without a
mask speaking of my own experience in
the cities over the past week and um
and over the past year
i'm not sure if i'm more depressed by
the sight of the homeless encampments
or the wealthy people in designer
clothing walking down the street outside
with masks on
and you know every single one of them
are vaccinated
so why is all that happening
is that another piece of the puzzle
and then what about the identity crisis
gripping our culture especially among
kids we've forgotten what the words man
and woman mean we look for for meaning
in these new and increasingly bizarre
redundant and contrived gender labels
meanwhile we again especially kids spend
most of our days staring at screens
consuming up to 10 hours of media a day
or more
the list of woes goes on and on and
there's probably no reason to keep
listing them
but it's important to look at all these
problems altogether because i would
suggest
that underneath all of this
there is a common root system
and the root system is despair
we are gripped in our society by a
crisis an epidemic of despair
we speaking in general terms we've lost
our sense of meaning and purpose which
is what it means to be in despair
when you have no collective sense of
meaning or purpose then your whole
civilization becomes like one of those
druggies on kensington just ambling
around hunched over
moaning and babbling to itself
nowhere to go nothing to do no sense
that there's any real
reason to exist in the first place now
it wasn't always like this in western
civilization we weren't perfect in the
past to put up mildly we had our flaws
there were very deep flaws as any human
civilization has flaws
because it is a civilization of humans
after all and not of angels
but we were rooted in a common
understanding and recognition of god's
providence
in our society
we believed
that we were children of god sent here
to do his will
now we may have fallen short of that
calling but we recognized the calling
and that calling gave us as a
civilization
a purpose a point a direction
but then over a period of years and
through a process that we don't have
time to document right now
god was removed from the picture
now not actually removed of course
because you can't
remove him really but we declared all
the same in nietzsche's phrase that god
is dead and that we no longer need him
that we can make our own meaning
but even nietzsche recognized that if
you're gonna kill god
kick him off the throne then you become
god and with that title
you inherent inherit an awful lot of
responsibility
whereas god gave us purpose and meaning
before
now if you're taking god out of the
equation
now you need to make your own purpose
and meaning
you will need to replace that god-sized
whole with something
but we never really bothered to figure
that part of it out
we kind of staged this mutiny and killed
the captain while we're out at sea but
nobody else on board knew how to
navigate
we said no no the captain is taking us
in the wrong direction we don't want to
go in that direction
so we took control of the ship and
instead of going in that direction
we went nowhere
we are now a society at drift
and it's up to each person to fill the
hole with something some people choose
drugs
some people choose to waste their lives
playing video games watching netflix
some look for meaning in their gender
identity or their critical theories of
race
everybody is
grasping at the air staggering around in
circles going nowhere
now you can't escape what i'm saying
here by simply
saying that you don't believe in god i
mean you could listen to this and say
well i don't believe in god so i don't
think that it is a problem
see the thing is whatever you believe
there's no question that western
civilization
once did believe
in god and now for the most part it does
not
there's also no question that the belief
gave a sense of purpose
there's also no question that when you
remove the purpose from a person or a
group
and you don't replace it with any kind
of new purpose
then you will have ushered in despair
and hopelessness without offering any
remedy for it
a hundred years into this process and
still none of the people who've worked
to remove god from the center of our
cultural life have come up with anything
to put into that place
that's the story of modern leftism
destroy but don't rebuild
erase definitions
don't offer new definitions
shout no we don't want to go that way
without saying where else we should go
and this is where we've ended up as a
result
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content